ja ich will jetzt nicht sagen dass wir
das nächste auf den sack geht aber es
kann halt schon das ist irgendwie ein
bisschen überflüssig weil man da teilt
so oft beantworten muss
hey leute was glaubt netz bekommen bei
einem neuen video und zwar wie ihr
bestimmt schon gelesen habt geht's heute
um probleme eines singles ich denke man
sollte da zuvor ein bisschen was zu
sagen also ich hab halt ehrlich jetzt
darüber nachgedacht ob ich als nächstes
jetzt probleme jedes singles mache oder
halt vorteile jedes ding ich sag ich mal
so jetzt aber irgendwie probleme jedes
singles fand ich dann ein bisschen
interessanter habt es war aber sehr
schwer da halt viele dinge zu finden
weil vorteile gibt es schon deutlich
mehr ist immer so aufgefallen deswegen
jetzt die frage an euch falls ihr bock
auf vorteile oder irgendwie sowas jedes
ding ist habt dann lassen doch nach oben
dran weiß bescheid dann gibt's das video
auch noch und ansonsten wünsche euch
jetzt viel spaß
ich mach das video weil ich mega rock
pop und nicht weil ich jetzt single bin
sondern weil es halt so themen dass ein
gutes thema für mich und deswegen gibt
es heute ja dann wünsche euch viel spaß
mit dem video
wir fangen wir mal mit punkt eins an und
ich hätte nicht gedacht dass das so
krasses aber das geht auch vor allem auf
facebook so rum oder spezielles anwalt
so halt so an die singles man sieht
immer so viele pärchen wisst ihr
und ich habe mich damit jetzt nie so
wenig befasst und das ist aber wirklich
so also guck mal ich weiß die letzten
zwei wochen oder so war ich mal darunter
und du siehst echt überall irgendwo hält
so welchen und vorher wenn man eine
beziehung ist fällt etwas weil ich so
krass auf ich will jetzt nicht sagen
dass negativ für mich ist aber das ist
schon so und ich weiß auch nicht woran
das liegt aber das ist irgendwie so ich
keine ahnung was auch noch ein ziemlich
großes problem ist also einst von den
zwei großen probleme meiner meinung nach
das andere war noch das andere große
problem und zwar wenn jetzt freunde eine
freundin haben und die halt an dem tag
oder an dem abend was mit ihrer freundin
machen anstatt mit dir wenn man jetzt so
in einer beziehung ist dann denkt man
sich natürlich so ja okay kein ding dann
war ich halt auch was mit meiner
freundin aber
man hat da nicht einer beziehung ist
sondern single dann problem hallen
fahrzeug machen okay eigentlich sollte
ich mitte juli ins spiel bis in piepers
auch ganz angenehm aber so handelt er
ist halt ein problem würde ich mal sagen
eins der zwei großen ja ich will jetzt
nicht sagen dass mir das nächste auf den
sack geht aber es kann halt schon das
ist irgendwie ein bisschen überflüssig
weil man hat halt so oft beantworten
muss und zwar geht man ja auch wenn man
jetzt eine freundin hat wird macht halt
andauernd gefasste freuden und wenn man
keine freunde hat wird man auch anderen
gesagt ey hast du eine freundin oder ich
lese das auch so oft dass das bezieht
jetzt vielleicht auch etwas anderes aber
voll viele schreiben mir so ja hast du
eine freundin blablabla und da denkt man
sich so soll ich euch jetzt 10.000 mal
die gleiche geschichte erzählen oder
keine ahnung aber trage ich also viele
hast du eigentlich noch eine freundin
und dann erzähle ich immer ne ich hab
keine freunde mehr
dann fragen warum oder jo erzählt sind
10.000 leuten die gleiche story und das
ding geht ein bisschen auf den sack und
das ist auch so ein problem eines
singles würde ich mal sagen er hat eine
freundin hatte gar nicht punkte ist wenn
man jetzt so sich denkt ach ich könnte
eigentlich mal wieder ein foto wie
instagram oder so machen dann kann man
jetzt als weibliche person seine beste
freundin fragen von wegen
hey baby süße was weiß ich wie ich dahin
ist dieses bild de
oder ist es gar keine ahnung ich weiß
nicht wie untereinander seid gefragt
weil mehr ist als bild geil
keine ahnung und dann bekommt ihr halt
eine antwort und so als nun kann man
natürlich dann auch mal wenn meine
beziehung ist eine freundin fragen ob
das bild hübsches oder nicht und wird
dann entweder aus glatt weil es scheiße
ist oder das bild ist rein ins programm
oder so deswegen als männlicher single
kann man halt jetzt nicht so wissen okay
das jetzt gut oder nicht gut das foto
und man kann halt auch nicht so seine
freude freiheit kommt ein bisschen ihr
wisst schon über es mir auch mal so
aufgefallen und der letzte punkt ist ich
habe einfach viel zu viel geld zurzeit
ich habe zu viel geld meine geld haben
kommt zu mir ich gebe euch ein bisschen
nein spaß das war nur ironie aber man
echt
ziemlich viel geld und ja ist ja
eigentlich was gut ist aber man kann es
auch so ironisch als problem sehen sagen
immer so und ja ich würde sagen falls
euch das video feuer das auf jeden fall
daumen nach oben da hier ist nummer fed
instagram eingeblendet und ansonsten
würde ich sagen wir sehen uns mit ob wir
hier auf der linken seite geht's weiter
mit meinem ex mio
das war hier fünf arten von unterricht
und hier auf der anderen seite mit lasst
euch überraschen abonnieren vergessen um
nichts zu verpassen und wir sehen uns
dann wie gesagt eben mittwoch wieder
verändert